[Music]
i like that
oh did you see what alex stein's doing
to state capitol there was an abortion
protest
sit
this
this came out around the same day yes
yes yes yes this is yes yes correct yes
babies they're losers this is the future
these are young kids oh my god
he sat there like he was with them
didn't let them know what he was doing
until he started filming look at their
faces look at their faces look at their
faces murder babies they sit here in the
capitol and protest how they want to
murder babies they're losers this is the
future these are young kids
well first of all first by the way they
just told alex stein no one's going to
watch this
first of all alex stein
mr primetime 99 if that is your real
name
uh
stop harassing our girl esther prowitzky
that's
no she's from trash tuesdays
and uh you know we goof on her but don't
you know don't be mean nor macdonald was
mean to her once
people are gonna watch it these people
are baby murderers
they do the [ __ ] [ __ ] eating grin all
the time with this guy man
you got like three yeah that's exactly
how many i got these people are
literally murdered that's exactly how
many i got
right here and everybody's gonna see
this and everybody's going to know
you are a baby murderer you know that
she'd probably still [ __ ] him whether
you want to admit it or not you guys
murder babies you're disgusting
like if you're playing cards look at
this look how pathetic these signs are
this is disgusting
i love that he grabs their signs
that's my favorite part that's the level
that alex stein's taking takes it to
that i think is hilarious to me when he
starts grabbing their signs notice
something he didn't break him
he just looked at it and put it down
yeah look how disgusting this is i want
to murder babies this is pathetic you
guys
throws it down
like the [ __ ] trash it is you're
[ __ ] such an [ __ ] alex and i love
you for it buddy that is what is [ __ ]
hilarious to me
these are pathetic losers these are
ma'am were you even alive when kurt
cobain was alive
nirvana shirt
these are both why don't you follow in
the footsteps of your hero yeah [ __ ]
seriously have your wife murder you
murderers
[Music]
oh i mean kill himself we're going with
the official story i apologize these
babies these people are baby murderers
this is we just knocked another poster
that's so stupid pathetic
this is the world we live in these
little kids sit here and they protest
and they want to kill little kids
it's pathetic it's sad
why is there an old man there
because someone who was there an old man
there
he just was tired and wanted to sit down
yeah
what are you guys doing here
um we're here
oh now he's playing when he first got
there oh what a dick to legalize
to legalize it
you don't think it's bad
i don't know why that's getting me so
much you don't think it's bad
it sounds like the idiocracy guy right i
know you brought him up yesterday like
why do you think that
you robbed
[Laughter]
[Music]
wow
you guys are pro-abortion
[Music]
which is pro-abortion right i mean
you can believe it but at least say what
you are right
we're at the capitol and this is at a uh
abortion protest so you guys just sit
here all
oh my god this day
crazy notice something
go back to that sign the last sign that
he had on the screen that one the one
with the big red they had to add in the
aav part
because they deny females the aav is
assigned at birth oh my god they make
the sign and then they had to get
stickers that were not the same font you
are
100
percent
correct look look at the sign they had
to let me see if i could just maybe go
back just a little bit more they had to
put an asterisk by it so that people
knew what the [ __ ] they meant oh but i
know i know no but there's so much going
on here right so this official initially
just said
texas public officials are
inhumane and unfit to hold office if
they vote to deny females abortions when
their health is at high risk then some
trans activist or somebody came up to
them and was like ah what do you mean by
females you mean assigned at birth so
they have to go to [ __ ] put get three
stickers from cvs
but just it's just like what like
if i were a leftist political activist i
would have already just been exhausted
and given up already good eye virgie
jesus christ
[ __ ] that's funny autism what does it
i think it's the autism what does it to
them too
you know why should we blame someone for
getting pregnant why should we shouldn't
they use protection
it's not a bad question good good cop
over here that's only 99 alex stein's
the only person who's good cop and bad
cop and the same person or 90 percent
effective actually contraception is only
nice
so like the baby though you don't think
it's bad it has a heartbeat and stuff
and you're just killing i don't think it
is a baby i don't think it personally
what do you think it is
but it's not going to grow to be a dog
did you hear
i i
i will say this bill burr did have a a
pretty f a pretty funny joke about
abortion
in his new special i i just i just saw
the clip of it [ __ ] me so i can find it
it's my body my choice that's right man
she's right i'm not gonna put the video
so we don't get popped okay it's my body
my choice that's right man she's right
leave me the hell alone oh you're
killing a baby well i mean there is that
well
i mean you know we're going to be honest
that is the whole purpose of the
procedure
you're going in there because you're
like i got a baby you mean get the [ __ ]
out of here
right you walk in with the baby you come
out without one what happened to the
baby right
pro-choice people like well it's not a
life yet it's not a baby yet if you do
it when they say i'm not a doctor but
i'll tell you my gut tells me that okay
no but the [ __ ] they cut the joke out
the part of the joke that was actually
my god tell me
something [ __ ] happened so
pro-choice people like well it's not a
life yet it's not a baby yet if you do i
don't know what they say before you do
the first thursday or the last tuesday
it's center hour time
they danced between the ray trucks
it's not a baby yet that's what they say
which may or may not be true i don't
know i'm not a doctor but i'll tell you
my gut tells me that doesn't make sense
it's not a baby yet that would be like
if i was making a cake and i poured some
batter in a pan and i put it in the oven
and then five minutes later you came by
and you grabbed the pan you threw it
across the floor
and what the [ __ ] he just ruined my
birthday cake
i know you were like that wasn't a cake
it's like well it would have been
you didn't do what you just did there
would have been a cake in 50 minutes
something happened to that change you
take murder and son of a [ __ ]
so i thought [ __ ] genius that was
really good i thought that was a good
good analogy the cake thing
it would have been a cake
it doesn't matter which one broke me
it's what it is now it's like thomas
could you imagine if you all got aborted
would you have been happy if your
parents aborted you okay i know we
wouldn't have those abortions are done
selectively you know that they
electively do i don't think it matters
see it should matter you know and see
this is people that are in for a choice
because there should be a limit so do
you think there should be a limit
so you think up until birth you should
be able to afford a baby see that's evil
and demonic these people are demonic
they want to murder and that's where it
started and that's where it started okay
then we don't have to you know obviously
by the way but
i just wanted to see what what the uh
what the point was when he turned on him